Hello everybody welcome back to the
corridor digital podcast what's up
episode 182 what's going on everybody I
haven't been in a podcast for a long
time yeah we missed we found Nico in the
back hall of the studio he was lost we
brought him back and now here he is he's
lost
yeah we're well I'm finally back for an
important reason I mean if people
watched any videos this weekend they've
seen the announcement but rock paper
scissors too anime rock paper scissors 2
is coming out in a week at least a week
of from when this podcast drops well six
days technically from this podcast yeah
and uh I like the style of like not
announcing anything until it's really
close like that's the way I like to do
it versus like in three years the new
video game will come out they're looking
for it it's like whatever you know like
announce it like like the new tears of
the Kingdom or like comes out in three
months you're like whoa you know you get
hyped so yeah rock paper scissors too
we've been working on it since the first
one came out so basically almost five
months ago four-ish months ago yeah nose
down grinding for like the past two
months just every day doing shots and
getting it out there and it's finished
and it's coming out in a week on
quarterdigital.com so yeah can't tell
you guys it's been a journey and the
um the improvements it's
it's hard to watch the first one after
seeing some of the shots
it's like the first one was very Cutting
Edge and groundbreaking and really cool
and fun but
this one just it's like it's just so
much more polished yeah well you know
it's like the whole idea of this
technology at the end of the day is
still to serve a story to make something
cool and we're like man if we can do you
know six-ish minutes or so for the first
one let's let's do a full episode let's
go hard let's write a full episode of
this wacky anime called anime rock paper
scissors and so we did and then we shot
it we started shooting it and you know
about halfway through we're like oh my
gosh this is a lot
you know like the first rock paper
scissors had 80 shots and the new one
has almost 400 shots and it's not just
like the process isn't just about like
the AI part of it you know effectively
the the AI rotoscoping part of it but
it's still you know like twice as many
or more shooting days uh we have
multiple characters they have multiple
costumes they have way more environments
just the pipeline because every single
shot is a visual effect shot when you're
doing an animation so you have to have a
pipeline to manage every single shot
getting edited getting labeled getting
being exported into a proper folder
structure getting put into a spreadsheet
going out to different teams going
through different stages of Polish and
it yeah you basically we had to invent a
whole post-production workflow to try to
make it so you could actually violated
that was one thing that typically you
find on Bigger Productions oh I guess
Eliza is bringing me my phone see you
later one thing you find on on Bigger
Productions yeah is uh this concept of a
technical editor or like a
I'm not sure if that's the right word
but somebody who's whose job it is is
just to make sure that everything in the
timeline is supposed to be where it's
supposed to be yeah because you get when
you it's true when you get 400 shots you
get 15 minutes usually 15 minutes is
pretty manageable you usually get this
on like TV shows and movies but for this
circumstance it was necessary but you
get all those different layers in there
and you need somebody to just make sure
that things are labeled correctly the
heads and tails are correct it's it's
matched with the right file Source like
because that stuff can become a
nightmare anybody who's edited anything
beyond just like a DSLR camera with
basic audio knows that timelines can
become a nightmare yeah 100 yeah
yeah so we you know we built out a team
for this you know Dean has Dean and Sam
are basically like the other two people
that have been uh as involved as me like
in this process like we're kind of like
the core three and then from there uh
Matthias has been been our technical
editor as you described uh plus he's
helped do some compositing kenson
um also known as recognition on
Instagram he's an amazing animator he's
been helping us out with a bunch of
shots as well and then we had this so
you have this thing where okay you write
it you shoot it on the green screen you
edit it you have all these shots okay so
you then you train up uh you know an AI
model to replicate these shots into a
cartoon style but then you now have 400
charts shots shots you know 400 shots
that need to go through this process but
they also need to be composited and all
that kind of stuff so we actually built
this team this bounty hunting team of AI
artists that would help us out they'd
grab the shots that we had and they
would process those on their end we'd be
processing our shots on our end and all
of us kind of worked together just to
try to stay ahead of the other like team
that was doing all the compositing and
trying to just then take these shots cut
them out put them on a background Etc we
had an artist named kaitra uh who has an
amazing like array of like AI work that
she's been working on uh it's really
cool stuff Jan helps us out a little bit
another guy named uh Eric or enigmatic e
uh he actually has a YouTube channel
with a whole bunch of great tutorials on
how to install this stuff and get
started uh they all jumped in and helped
out helped us process shots and it was a
really good time and you know I think
one of the first things that people are
probably going to ask us is did we make
our own style this time around or did we
use Vampire Hunter D again and yes this
time around we made our own style that
was actually one of the very first
there's one of the things we wanted to
do initially but I think what got Lost
in Translation is like we're also a
YouTube channel that does experiments
and just does things for fun and when we
do that we're not really worried about
intellectual properties we're just
making stuff right yeah yeah because
otherwise you just get it's like a hard
stop you know and you you can't you
can't really do that when you're
experimenting and developing yeah and
I'm a big proponent of like approaching
art like that like nothing's really off
limits it's ideas right and like sure
somebody can have an idea and kind of
have it be their signature but like oh
Michael Bay does cool explosions with
orange and blue color tinting you can't
do it like no screw that what if I want
to do it I'm going to do it like I like
that style of martial arts I like that
style of you know et cetera Etc but I
also get that if you're going to then do
something commercially and like take it
to that next step you do have to not
just rip somebody else off and make it
your own thing but you know with the
first rock paper scissors to us is an
experiment but a lot of people saw that
as us like intentionally ripping off
Vampire Hunter D for their aesthetic
this time around it was a success yeah
because we thought we didn't even know
if we were going to release anything we
didn't even know if it started that road
yeah when we started down that road
so yeah yeah you can't make it you can't
make data sets you can't make concept
art when you don't even know what kind
of Concepts all right step one is
concepting yeah let's just let's just
start with an anime that already exists
and see if we can even make our video
look like it that's where we were right
but then that came out I think everybody
kind of took it for granted that it
worked
um not everybody some people
um
but regardless like if you're an artist
and you're creating at some point you
want it to be your voice you want it to
be your thing you don't want to be
everybody like hey you're you're things
cool but it really looks like this thing
then you just feel like you're a second
tier right you want to be your own thing
um and so this time around we developed
our own art style basically uh I reached
out to a buddy of mine that I've known
since college named Josh Newland and had
him or asked him to basically draw the
characters in the new costumes that we
had you know played by Dean and myself
and we also have Sam as a character my
wife Ivy is a character Jordan Allen is
a character in this
um
we had him draw these characters and he
drew them in a style that was similar to
the first vampire or this was the first
anime rock paper scissors but it's very
much his style also like it has the
signature way in which he draws human
faces and that kind of stuff which I
really like which is why I reached out
to him he also did old uh Corridor
T-shirts from way back in the day if
anybody has one of the original like
chord or digital t-shirts we used to do
and it was very much inspired by Vampire
Hunter D like yeah to be to be fair to
that show I mean there's stylistically
we liked that style yeah the gothic
anime the 90s look yeah but yeah it's
like a that is a distinct aesthetic
across that period of anime like it's
just kind of like a touchstone for
something that you look at it and it
definitely has its own unique style but
you look at it and it just feels like
this is that like Gothic and RRP style
anime Rock Paper Scissors
because like it like the reason that
we're using Vampire Hunter D in the
first piece is like this is a parody of
anime yeah parody loving parody event
loving parody but yes and this is
not a generic film but it's like this is
a the style that people recognize as
being anime so like yeah if you were if
we had brought on if we had a whole
animation team to make that piece we
would say look at vampire Mr D because
this is a parody
and like you feel like going forward
with this one because it's a full
episode because it's trying to build a
world and stuff it's like it's gotta
find its own voice I agree uh yeah I
mean that was very much what we were
trying to do and there's also the big
question of like okay yeah sure when we
can pull 100 pictures from a cartoon
that already exists sure it's easy
enough to make a data set can we do it
from scratch now which is a question we
had to ask ourselves and an experiment
we had to do and the answer is yes and
it's a lot of work but yes it is
entirely possible and there's cool
things you can do in the process with
these tools to let you say take 15
pictures that you've created and turn
that into a full-blown data set versus
like having to draw 150 pictures
um but yeah you know yeah it was crazy
how fast it got it yes which is I think
just one of the really cool things about
we thought I have to do maybe double or
even triple the amount of assets we gave
it and we started with one batch just
thinking oh
let's just see kind of how it does and
it it got it really quickly yeah it's
interesting because like
you know Josh started off doing pictures
of Dean's character I believe uh Prince
of Jules exiled Prince Jules and then he
moved on to doing drawings of King
Philip on my character
and they went on to doing drawings of
Sam he did just some generic drawings of
like care like just people in this world
uh he did the Queen Elizabeth
um and as he did this we also kept
adding these to just an overall data set
of his art so that we could if we had
another character that just needed to
show up for like a frame we could just
generically apply his art interpretation
to that character and it wasn't super
consistent like you couldn't use it for
a main character but as we'd create our
data sets for characters we could also
take this like overall data set and
bring them together and as the project
went on we were able to get more and
more of his style Terence translated
into the video that we were filming
which was cool we also we have Jonah in
the room with us today yeah sorry I've
just been listening this has been what
I've been doing because I'm I'm helping
make uh some of the the videos about
this so I'm like I kind of feel like I'm
at my desk right now listening to the
video that I'm editing and I love it
yeah so Jonah's here because Jonah has
been uh basically like co-writing
editing co-directing directing that code
erecting but directing the video essay
quarter crew video just went up
yesterday I believe relative to this
podcast release date yeah
um and it'll be it'll be in a week oh
wait yeah
oh you're right you're right yeah I got
my timelines all screwed up so there's
videos coming out in like yeah five or
six coming out same day as uh as anime
rock paper scissors on Corridor yeah and
Jonah what have you been trying to do
with that video essay it's it's a very
uh delicate video
um you know we haven't really talked
publicly about the response to anime and
we haven't talked about what we're doing
with the second one since it came out uh
and so we're taking this time before the
video comes out to really uh Prime the
audience on on why we're doing this and
what our new process is and a lot of it
kind of is what you just touched on uh
some of the biggest things that we're
talking about in that video is is this
new pipeline
um which I find really interesting
um you know where you are designing a
new not just a a new way of doing
animation or what we're saying is in
some ways a new art form but we're
finding a new process of doing that and
I'm such a process junkie that that's
really the heart of the video for me is
is how to illustrate this process
um because
it is not owned by anyone uh this
process and I think that's really
important like the things that uh we're
showing in this video essay you can do
with your friends and there is really
nothing stopping you from doing that and
so that's our hope with with the video
essay is to uh show people that it is
accessible and and also to
to be a bit of a a beacon of like maybe
this is the way that we should do this
because it's it's tough and there's a
lot of gray area here so hey guys like
wait we're waving this flag like this is
how we do it you should maybe you should
try and let us know what you think but
this is the way that we're navigating
this crazy new uh Frontier
um not to say that we're doing it
perfectly but
but we're sure we're willing to show you
yeah yeah and and we've been I mean it's
been really fun to
see this come to light
um I mean we've been inventing like
words for positions on the process
because we don't know what to call it
like I've been calling some like Dean's
been doing processing it's like okay is
Dina like a processing artist you know
like what does that mean and and so it's
been fun inventing new new like
positions for it but then also
um like just for example we got this in
inquiry the other day from
this guy from this much bigger company
and he was asking us specifically if we
could do this certain type of commercial
for like this idea that they had and
the thing was
nobody that he had talked to knew
like what to do and and we barely
you know have an idea and that's kind of
where where it's at with the use of
these tools
um it's it's definitely further along
than it was six months ago or especially
a year ago before a lot of this stuff
even came out
um but yeah it's it's been really funny
having conversations with people from
these huge companies and them asking us
if we have a an idea of how to make
these things and that's going well we're
kind of experimenting with a pipeline
right now so you know give us some time
and we can figure it out and then be
like okay okay yeah yeah let's do it
um yeah it's just been it's been funny
to see so I'm really glad Jonah that
you're
documenting all that for people
of course yeah and and I to that point
Jake like I'm very curious for for you
both
it almost feels
and definitely from the audience's
perspective here kind of like this was
always going to happen once it's come
out people would be like well of course
they were going to do a sequel uh of
course it was going to be better right
this is just kind of what happens when
you make things but I guess my question
for the two of you is what has been the
most surprising thing that has happened
between the first and the second one the
thing that you didn't expect the thing
that has changed maybe the most
um because none of this just kind of
happened it was a lot of trial and error
um and we're carving out all these new
paths forward
and I'm sure you've been shocked
yourself at things that have happened
yeah Dean what do you kick it off uh I
would say the most
the biggest advancement I mean obviously
the characters look much better
but to me the biggest advancement has
been the backgrounds that Sam has been
generating yeah because I look at what
Sam's doing I mean it's the same process
as the first one opening you know a 3D
environment take a screenshot run that
through stable diffusion turn it into
like a painted
um background
but the aesthetic and the aesthetic is
pushed so much further but also the
details are so much more retained yeah
and I look at that and I'm like that is
already ready I mean there was the big
story about Netflix was using some AI
backgrounds for stuff but
that's already ready for
Studio level yeah you'll see if not
already you'll see that in Productions
yeah within the next year because like
the the character stuff I feel like
we still
we still do some a little bit of cleanup
we still do
uh things here and there to to push it a
little further
but I feel like character stuff is still
we're knocking on the door of this is
this is ready to go
uh no the care the characters the
character stuff you're knocking on the
door for which is because you you like
any AI process
it sort of
Smooths out some Nuance of performance
and of
things of that nature so
and I but I feel like you know there's
some tech that's just around the corner
that will push it over the line where
it's like okay this is
you know
ready for like a feature film or
something
um
but yeah it's it's just been cool
to see I mean we always joke about like
every week we're like oh this new thing
just came out that's gonna make this
50 to 100 better
um yeah and that you're always like do I
upgrade or do I just write it out it's
like do I invalidate all the work I did
up to this point yeah see that in the um
in one of the drafts that I watched uh I
could see where you guys you started
using the control net
very clearly and Visually see it in the
in the timeline of the piece well and
that was the that was the very end of
the first one and control that game and
control net came out which essentially
oh here don't steal my big moment
just just to finish what you're saying
with background so like
taking an Unreal Engine screenshot and
then you know Sam is just basically
saying make it look like it's the exact
same screenshot but just painted with
watercolors like he's there's no
specific artist or anything like that
being called into it it's just literally
how would this line have been drawn if
it was done with a pencil versus if done
with pixels and that's all it is it's
just a medium transferral but it looks
so nice and now all the details persist
so well because control net so that
totally changed the game on the
backgrounds and then to me the other big
thing was well I'm gonna tell it as a
little bit of a story because it's
always nice little bit of drama so we
start working on anime rock paper
scissors too because we're like you know
what we need to come back we need to do
it better and show people what we got a
lot of people loved rock paper scissors
one some people were very angry by rock
paper scissors one we needless to say it
made a mark across the board and we're
like well we got it we have to make a
second one we can't just step away from
this right we have to take a shot so
we're like we're gonna do it better do
it bigger we do it faster we're gonna be
cool
and we start doing our shots and we did
this scene where we have a scene where
we're young boys and we're like more
like generic anime characters and it was
working really well and like damn this
is a really big step up and it was
basically just the refined process from
the first rock paper scissors with the
additional control net which lets you
kind of constrain the image a little bit
more which is great for us because we're
putting it onto a video of us acting out
as these characters
um
but as we got to the part where we're
older and we're adults it just wasn't
working very well it was really flickery
it was hard to get the art style to come
through and we were struggling we were
struggling and like man this is just
gonna be a slog we have to do this for
400 shots you know it's gonna be
impossible
um and I'd seen there's this tool called
warp fusion and you've probably seen
versions of it where like you know it's
probably like a tick tock dance and it's
going through a bunch of different
filters or it's like just a warpy thing
where it just goes for like just LSD
style visuals
um but I'd seen some of those coming out
recently and like they're a lot more
persistent with details than they had
been in the past and the guy who makes
warp fusion Alex had implemented this
reconstructed noise thing that we had
used in our first rock paper scissors
yet Incorporated that into warp as well
um for my request and I was like you
know it's time to jump back in and take
another look at this program and I
basically locked myself in the office
for like a whole day didn't talk to
anyone worked on one single shot like
because you have to go in like read this
weird archaic code and you're trying to
figure everything out like navigating
through githubs and pythons and you know
various installs and stuff and then
finally by the end of the day
working my way through all these
parameters I have no idea what any of
them even mean like oh what's your flow
latent blend schedule it's like
I don't know I don't know your flow
latent blend schedule come on I mean
should be zero comma 40 or what I don't
know zero comma 35 at the most we
actually settled on zero comma 60 and
zero comma six in a clip uh Max of 0.1
I mean that's a good example of like
what we're trying to figure out here
it's just like it's these weird it could
be just Gerber factor and like blooper
factor and like you just come with a
number until it looks good
um anyways lock myself in the office
figured it out got a shot out and it was
way better it was way more stable it was
way more consistent way more clear I
remember showing UD and you're like
that's pretty good and yeah I'm like
yeah it's pretty good and then like the
next week we come back after the weekend
and start running some more shots I
think actually no I ran them all
throughout the weekend I didn't stop
like everyone home for the weekend I
used every single computer in the office
to test every parameter in that program
and just run things I was running eight
machines simultaneously side by side for
about 48 hours straight and then on
Monday everybody comes back like guys I
figured it out this project is saved
it's gonna be rad check it out and then
I'm showing everybody these warps
they're just we call them warps now
because they come out of warp fusion and
they're just the cleanest like AI
rotoscope basically that you could
possibly imagine and it just holds so
much potential because
when you can fine tune this a diffusion
model to represent something that you
want to represent you can like for
example you could make a character in
metahuman you could render out a bunch
of angles of that character wearing
whatever costume and then you could fine
tune a diffusion model to replicate that
character and now like using warp fusion
for example stick that onto video of
yourself and turn yourself things get
insane yes and this is like this is the
crazy part that's hard to even
comprehend because five years ago this
was an insane concept yeah but that's
what you can do you can yeah forget
cartoons for a second like anime is cool
at all but it's not about anime we're
doing this because of what this really
is is the world's most powerful visual
effects program because you can take a
video and you can turn it into anything
I could turn you into an alien I could
turn you into a monster I could turn you
into a bug like I could take a meta
human character render out 200 pictures
of it fine tune them all to replicate
that meta-human character and I can
record you doing a dance and I'll just
turn you into the metahuman character
rather than having to motion cap for you
import the motion capture anime station
rendered on blender you don't have to do
any of that right theoretically right
once again we are not in that world yet
this is us dreaming big but we are
taking steps to get to that world and
there's little things that have been
done in anime rock paper scissors too
even like for example we didn't use this
exact method I won't reveal the the
secret sauce until you get to that point
in the process but we had to do some
shots and we effectively used what would
be like oh meta-human character doing
this in this pose with this costume on
and then ran it through the filters that
were built by this point and it was in a
matter of five minutes of just getting
getting this specific frame from this
one program and then running it through
the next program and then in 15 minutes
we had this shot that we needed
yeah I mean it was a still but still it
doesn't matter it's like you could do it
with shots too yeah yeah that's been the
process like as we've gotten to the end
of the process I think
we're
our like imaginations are opening up to
the possibilities of like oh if I need
this thing
all I need to do is this like uh if I
need like I have the model of Jordan
Allen's character and there's a shot
where I need a group of his character in
the background he's a soldier he plays
every soldier in this world so the
kingdom is played by one man which is
Jordan now
that's very anime you know yeah drop one
guy and then just have him do a bunch of
different stuff
so uh in you know with control net you
can use uh uh this thing called open
pose which basically looks at a photo of
a person gets the pose and then tries to
apply your prompt if it's a person apply
that pose to that character essentially
so I would just be like oh I need a
group of people I would I would type in
group of soldiers on the internet grab
the poses from that group of soldiers
and then put Jordan Allen in the and he
now it's just Jordan Allen sitting
around like a bunch of exactly like the
the shot right right it's crazy and then
it's like I you know go on Photoshop use
AI tools of Photoshop to just instantly
select the subjects cut them out and
then I can just put them in the
background of a shot duplicate them and
it's just like within literally
five minutes I have like a a bunch of
Jordan Allen's just walking around in
the background yeah and the magic there
like the magic there is that we're
creating our own like fine-tuned model
yeah that's that's where it all comes
together is that we've we're creating a
character we're creating the style we're
bringing it all together generating
these pictures of the character creating
a whole data set for that and being like
okay only draw this learn how to only
draw this take all this generalized
knowledge that you know you have as a
general model of how to draw everything
and then learn how to just apply it all
to this and once you do that now it's
like okay I have I have a model I have a
little neural network that can bring
this one character to life and then you
know do poses you can't wait to keep
doing this and then have like what is a
virtual archive which is basically like
a warehouse and it's like you have
little potions on the shelf and it's
like oh what's that oh that's uh late
80s and early 90s Cinema
oh yeah this is is a Blade Runner that's
the Blade Runner feature
they're capturing Souls like we have so
many people like so many models made of
people that like you there's just this
folder on the server now of like you can
generate pictures of any of us doing
anything it's too much because Sam's got
my damn voice too now yeah Sam's got
your voice yeah you're gonna be the
villain of anime rock paper scissors
three but you don't know yeah yeah you
guys aren't even gonna tell me that's
the thing exactly you guys have enough
information now where you wouldn't even
have to tell me
we need this we need we're gonna make
metahuman we're gonna do a base filter
we're gonna run it a couple different
ways
got your voice
but Nico did you get to finish the warp
fusion point because that is obviously
the most important part I mean the
process really at the end of the day
it's like you know we're trying to
replicate right now we're trying to
replicate hand animation because it's
such a work time consuming working work
intensive time consuming process that
while there is a lot of creativity there
is also a lot of TDM like let's be real
you draw a key pose and you draw another
key pose you still got feel in all those
frames and that that can get pretty dang
tedious that is not necessarily a fun
artistic Endeavor that's there's no
other way to do this so we have to do it
by manual hand labor right
um and this was this process was
initially inspired by us wanting to make
an anime but not not knowing how to have
that pipeline not having those
traditional skills but also being like
let's just not even go that route right
now like let's just oh we're trying to
kind of touch upon the aesthetic is
there another way we can do it you know
let me jump to the AI version of that
but yeah it's like when we started using
warp fusion like the lines and the
clothes stand in the same spot and the
wrinkles stayed in the same spot and you
didn't have to D flicker it to have that
happen it just it was stable right from
the get-go and that was such a like it
was so cool to run it out of the program
and before you even start de-flickering
or anything like that you can just look
at it and be like oh that's that's
beautiful looks great I can see the
expression I can see the lip sync it's
wonderful like to see that already
before it gets processed and all VFX
stuff it was
that's what really like energized us and
it helped push us forwards and it's
funny because it's really the second
half
of the of the piece where
the faces and all the characters it
starts to look really good specifically
like you and Ivy's character Elizabeth
like there's a dialogue scene between
you two where I'm like oh my God that's
that looks like real anime like that's
at the beginning of the first one what
we were hoping to achieve one day yep
and that's like the full
uh yeah full embodiment of that I think
we're only I mean there's always going
to be little nuances with how it
produces out a shot but and and but the
nice thing is that'll become part of the
style over time and that'll become
recognizable with a certain era of a
certain style of this type of tool
for storytelling but I think we're only
like one or two more of these away from
really having
an almost imperceivable
difference between
traditional
hand animation and frame animation in
this yeah in terms of the temporal
consistency in terms of the consistency
yeah because of course hand animation
has the ability to move and warp in ways
that real life doesn't yeah but that's
not to say like so what if you instead
train a model on your cartoon character
well and you just draw your cartoon
character as a line drawing but you've
trained it up so then it can just
automatically get colored yeah and Inked
and shaded that's the most exciting part
we're getting into this territory too
where we can do 3D models we can do
really rudimentary 3D models and have
them do things like right now liquify
video to make it all wobbly yeah we've
been doing everything you know humans
green screen very very like working
playing to the strengths of what the
program can provide but you know you get
into this world with animation where you
say oh well why aren't they having a
fight with mechanical T-Rexes in the
middle of the ocean it's animation you
can do anything well with a little bit
of either
hand animating that or 3D animating that
you you can get there yeah in a couple
more steps yeah it's it's really
exciting stuff and like I there's such a
broad like way of looking at this that
like you know I don't want people to get
too copy like oh you just turned video
into an anime cool like it's like yeah I
know but like you can turn this is the
world's best visual like video filter
right you can turn anything into
anything and like imagine you know
busting out a really mediocre 3D render
of a character and just being like make
it look like it was rendered with a
better rendering engine you know or like
just here's you know my character acting
in a 3D program it's like cool just make
it a little more detailed and get rid of
The Uncanny Valley effect you know it's
like you can still have all this power
and all this creative control but the
tedium and those little bits and Bobs
they don't have to be like they don't
have to be something you have to deal
with if you don't want to not yet but
we're on the path that's that's the
future we're looking towards right
that's what we're trying to get to I
feel like the the 3D application are
super exciting because it is almost a
rendering engine it is a rendering
because the thing is a lot of uh uh a
lot of the data that you can get out of
a 3D program like depth like normal Maps
those are things now that you can use uh
with control net and other things are
coming out to inform the image
Generations so it's like 3D is actually
the optimal
uh uh use case because you can just like
you're saying you can take the most
basic render and make it look like
anything you want it's not like you're
saying it's it's not just we're doing
animation we're doing I mean it could
like think of all the
um visual mediums that are like almost
impossible to to make uh feature length
films out of like the there was the what
was the van Gogh yeah oil every frames
an oil painting yeah which is like oh
that's so much work so much work and
like you're saying like most of it is a
ton of tedium but like what if you as an
artist you can paint one frame and then
trying to model on that yeah and then
and you only paint frames that you think
need expression yeah you know right this
is where yeah yes this is where the
tedium becomes useful
because you can
Define and and create new styles
through that tedium without having to do
it every single time just to get the end
result yeah and that's the real thing
that I don't know if people quite get
but that to me that's like the biggest
value yeah like it can step in
to the parts of the process that you as
the artists don't want to do like if you
want to do a step you can totally do
that step and improve it on in that way
but like back to anime I really think
you know like this way of approaching
things you could never do like the
uh what's that shot up in Attack on
Titan where is it Levi who's like yeah
going through line to the street and
flying through the streets can't do that
with this process but you could do I
mean how many dialogue scenes where in
anime are there where there's just two
characters sitting across from each
other and the mouth is just moving right
like but an artist has to sit there and
draw
you know each one of those new frames of
the character like that's the stuff that
you could just train a model on the
character from you know not just
20 drawings but 100 drawings 150
drawings and now for the dialogue scenes
Boop you're done that you can focus on
the voice acting all the other things
that are important for those sequences
and then you have even more animation
bandwidth and time to put into the
awesome scenes that people talk about
with the craziest uh you know 2D uh
intentional animation there's very much
like a glass half full versus glass half
empty perspective here where I think a
lot of people look at a process like
this that makes things easier like well
that's just going to eliminate that's
just gonna eliminate artists and what's
been our experience here at Corridor is
it just means the amount of artists we
have can now output bigger and better
things so you can always you can look at
things like this tools that Empower
people you can always look at it as like
well I guess it just means you need less
people
but I think history if you look at it in
this process when it's happened with
other endeavors while there can be
shifts and things like that the reality
is is that it just enables more output
from the same amount of people you know
I'm sure Industries are going to shift
not necessarily because in general that
they'll be you know some shifts within
the way that things have been
traditionally done but at the same time
because of those shifts there will also
be exactly what you're saying which is
more
potential
for more stories and more output and
then the things that you do that make
your story special you can really focus
on
without some of the tedium and without
some of the regularity that comes with
the traditional process so
that that's ultimately
what's gonna
happen I think I mean I I don't know how
else it couldn't at this point yeah
we're still a ways out but it's like
people people are acting like this is
gonna kill just kill art like oh Art's
gonna suck now but it's like right no
art is about the people consuming it
it's about the people who are receiving
that are I mean that's where art happens
is the people like consuming it and like
they're gonna always gravitate towards
things that are cool and that they [__]
with you know and uh if you're making
lazy I think the accurate term is [__]
with
that's bottom of the barrel
nobody's gonna care yeah but like you
know the new spider-verse movie came out
this year and every frame is
labored over and obsessed over the
tiniest details and that movie was
extremely successful and people have
myself
deeply moved by that movie and um the
amount of artistry that goes into it and
that's never gonna disappear but it's
like
now with a movie like that there's even
more that's that's possible it's like we
get to spend our time laboring over
every frame of anime rock paper scissors
two because the tedious aspect of like
filming it getting it turned into a
cartoon getting a cut out that's not
tedious anymore yeah you know getting it
cut out from background easy green
screen right that's that's what you say
I don't just sit there and notoscope it
cool technology made it faster for me
you know turning into a cartoon I don't
have to trace every single frame I don't
have to rotoscope it by hand I can use a
computer to do that but now I get to sit
there and spend my time animating it and
figuring out how I want to light it
what's the composition going to be and
how do things flow and how they move and
how's the edit feel and how's the music
like I get to focus on the things that
actually like really emotionally make a
difference it's like I get to focus on
the color of the house rather than like
still digging the hole at the foundation
blocks are gonna go in you know and
there's also an element of because
certain things are so much less time
intensive now
if a moment's not working
it's just like oh let's totally
recontextualize this moment or like we
just had something like that where I was
like oh this shot doesn't really work
let's just do a different angle all you
know go stand in this pose you know that
kind of thing whereas I'm sure with
traditional animation it's like that's
the drawing we got I'm really excited to
introduce some more things in hopefully
in the next one
wherever wherever this goes after this
but some things that aren't just the
green screen like film footage it's the
drama is great and I think the
storytelling kind of
like makes it what it is
um which is how are anime videos have
always been
but like when can we introduce
3D animal or like
I mean I think I think you start getting
really crazy with this stuff I mean I
think it'd be cool to do like a horror
piece with a monster that's like this
vague like amalgamation of shapes where
you're like you think you pin it down
for a second but then it kind of shifts
underneath your eyes like yeah this yeah
there's a million things to explore here
and we're just we're getting that first
step out and be I just want people to
know we're actually going to be doing a
full-on three-part tutorial Jonah's also
kind of spearheading that as well we're
going to go into everything here which
is how to fine tune and train your own
model on your own characters in your own
art style
how to
let's run all this diffusion Stuff how
to use warp fusion how to process your
video into a cartoon and then how to do
the compositing which like the unsung
hero well done song Here on all this is
the backgrounds but the second most
unsung hero the real unsung hero is the
compositing which is like it's you know
no one's excited about compositing
anymore right who gives a crap but at
the same time with this process
compositing was a joy that was the the
sandbox that was us with our action
figures making cool moments and there's
all these great tricks you can apply to
take your footage and just make it
amazing compositing is an art and sort
of like a genre of visual effects unto
itself 100 as it as it is like it's yeah
it's its own thing completely
I don't think a lot of people know what
compositing even is you know like in
terms of the subsection of visual
effects but it's the the basic idea for
those of you who don't know is just you
get all these parts together you get all
these what would you say at least to the
compositor would be raw material plates
yeah you have your plates you have your
footage you have your you take you take
all these different images and now it's
the compositor's job to actually make
them look like they belong in the same
frame
lighting and texture and yeah it's a
little imperfections yeah all of that
stuff well and also in this because we
have these
plates of animated characters but
they're just
you know it's a static background and
sometimes a static character it's also
on you to I mean really animate it and
yeah in the traditional sense of like
I'm gonna punch in at this moment I'm
gonna move the character there I'm gonna
I mean even sometimes like warp the arm
or something Sam was doing a lot of that
on these like big punching shots and
um I think it is still that is still you
know animation like especially yeah some
of the craziest shots in the piece are
just it's like yeah we put a cool video
filter on it but we basically like
animated this shot yeah the video filter
is like five percent ten percent of the
process I think I think that kind of
exemplifies the concept you were talking
about where you get to this point where
the first one the concentration really
was on like the technology like the AI
tools and then because it you guys
dialed it in so much exactly like what
you're saying with like if this was used
in traditional animation it's like but
you just got to spend time doing the
stuff that you really want to and if if
there's a difference that I saw between
the first and the second one surprise
I've seen it we've all seen it here uh
it's that
there is so much more animation to it
there's so much more love in the
compositing and the the way that she
does this man yeah it it it it is so so
much uh I can tell so much love has gone
into that and it's only because you guys
have had the space to do that yeah and
I'm really curious to see as as these
tools evolve and we get into using the
more how that's gonna evolve because
that's you guys are building a style
really
um that hasn't really been done before
uh and just from seeing the iteration
into the second one I think it's really
promising because it's it's immediately
fulfilling that ideal which is like if
we make part of the process easier will
it let us make more interesting art and
the jump from the first to the second
was like yes yeah it will yeah yeah
it was really fun like I mean I'm saying
as if it's done uploaded but like
technically there's like a little more
work to do but it was really fun like
parts were work of course but all of it
was like really inspiring and the the
rate at which like the material would
come out and you could like be making
stuff
was something that like really at least
kept me going because it's one thing
like let's say you're working on a a
crazy VFX shot
and you spend a whole day building the
scene cool you come in the next day now
you start setting up the scene for your
animation and you run your sim or
something like that cool and then you
rendered that night you wait 12 hours
for the thing to finish you come back
the next day ah you forgot to flip this
layer off fix it all tweak things again
come the next day so like now it's
grinding you down right yeah and sure
you get some results here and there but
you got like days and days of just like
grind before you get something out
whereas this this time it's like
try something hit a button wait a minute
okay guys tweak a little bit give
another minute okay two a little bit
more one more minute okay cool that's
good send that off to Big come back an
hour later okay it's done bringing your
composting program immediately start
composing hit play in real time okay put
it here put it here do this do this
that's my let's add this let's do it
they're like you're like a chef just
throwing food into the thing you know
you're not sitting there like hoe in the
field waiting for the corn to grow like
you're there at the stove cooking the
whole time the fun stuff the creativity
is so much more fluid I think in that
sense because you really
you're not
like you're not really thinking about
constraints anymore which is like you
know on one hand creativity needs
constraints but obviously there's still
constraints constraints of of time of
what the story needs all this stuff but
like every shot like every shot
it now becomes a question of like how do
I Elevate this because it's already got
it already looks cool it's already got
an animated character in there like all
that work is done how do I tell the
story even harder yep in this shot and
that was a question Sam took to heart
yeah you know it's where you know it's a
good process when Sam is just like
delivering you like five to eight insane
after effects animations like a day and
you're like how are you doing this yeah
are you kidding me how are you making
these shots first of all and how are you
getting so many of them through the pipe
I don't I don't get it yeah I feel like
I'd walk up until he gets going dude you
just get out of his way I'd like ask him
a question be like oh yeah you just
throw a gradient on it I'm like but how
does it look like that yeah
it's like a Grady I put a gradient on it
it doesn't look anything like that
yeah man I remember when we were working
on Battlefield and like you know we had
a VFX house do the vast majority of the
VFX there's like 15 to 20 shots that
like Sam just wasn't happy with and the
thing was like we had the thing had to
be like you know cut print in like a day
and Sam's just like I'm just gonna do
them and like he's saying you're like
the director one of The Producers like
you're not even part of the VFX house I
don't think you should really do this
he's like no I'm just gonna we have the
footage I'm just gonna do them I'm like
are you sure you have like maybe like
eight hours before it's dude it's like
I'm fine and he does like all of them
and they're all amazing
like Sam really ruins your expectations
when you're trying to deal with any
other like that is that what he does
saying like 15 layered explosion shot
yeah I did like the melting gold room
yeah just like the ball blows up and
like the Smoke Gets pulled out through
the like the new hole how are you
animating all this
yeah so good I I remember well basically
you you said
the warp fusion came out at the
beginning of or right at the end of
anime one control that or control that
and then we got warp fusion and you were
telling me today all right that you've
run into a similar problem yes uh so I
mean this one is anticipated we knew
this was gonna come out towards the end
of this project whereas control net was
a surprise but every single project we
do have to rush them a little bit
because the the AI stuff moves so fast
but today
sdxl dropped I don't know if that's what
you're yeah
I appreciate it you in fact you were so
on the nose of that queue up that I had
to kind of spoil it but
uh yeah so that we were our fine tunes
are based off the generalized stable
diffusion 1.5 bottle which is basically
a model that's looked at every picture
on the internet so to speak so you tell
it what a tree is you say a tree it
knows what a tree is a cloud knows what
a cloud is and it's Picasso like anybody
right so anything anybody the model the
model generally knows everything so when
you fine tune it onto like your own art
style it doesn't like forget what a hand
looks like now you can represent like a
hand in your art style but at least if
it sees a picture of a hand it generally
knows what they look like ironically I'm
using hands as an example considering
how it usually does a bad job of hands
but today they dropped sdxl which is a
new basically a new open source
generalized model they've been working
on for months and months and months and
it's weird in this world of AI where
everything is moving so fast and always
so fresh it's weird to think that we've
been on a Model that's almost a year old
yeah you know everything else is so new
but this model we've been using is
almost a year old we've been fine-tuning
it of course making it our own thing but
you know I just I wonder what would
happen if we fine-tune the new model and
I'm sure I'm sure like in three weeks
we'll try it out we'll try some other
you know new like tweaks and
improvements that have happened and it's
just gonna make rock paper scissors 2
look irrelevant but you know what that's
the game and then run down for that
because also at the end of the day
if you're if you're doing your pieces
the right way if you're making your art
the right way it doesn't really matter
what the technology is as long as it's
fun to watch and it serves the purpose
it needs and it tells a story and it's
just a good time then who cares who
cares it's made with Play-Doh or if it's
made with you know by Pixar as long as
the story is good and that the medium
serves the story and it works yeah and
that's like
you guys have made tons of anime videos
and they were live action they were live
action and it's no it's it's no
different I think there's just
there's the excitement around oh this is
new technology that's making these
visuals possible
and you know visuals they're like a
spectacle it's just like a big stunt in
a movie it's like this is really cool to
watch but at the end of the day what
you're saying it's all about the
characters it's all about the story are
you engaged with these people and what's
happening in their in their lives yeah
and um
and that's been another thing that's
been super fun about this one is like
there's a bunch of new characters and
you know the characters have a little
bit more depth now and like there's just
and that's that kind of anime thing
where it's like
season two of the anime like this
character is now totally flipped you
know and you get to see that side of
them and and like that that will always
be the most rewarding stuff no matter
what the technology is is like
the story yeah and some of the
advancements will slow down eventually
it just right now as with any
breakthrough we're in a breakthrough
period And so there's just
like all these things that are happening
based upon you know this this new sort
of structure that's been introduced for
how to write these machine learning
programs and that that'll slow down and
it'll stabilize and then you know the
the it'll hit
like a like a peak
phase of the technology and the use and
the expression I mean and you look back
on any format and you can see this
uh whether it's you know film or uh
music or yeah it's it's all got that
yeah yeah everything marches forward
right it's interesting to see but you
know the first rock paper scissors we
had two characters three if you count
the king the dead King who doesn't move
at all
um
in the new rock paper scissors
we have
one two three four five six seven eight
we have eight characters
um the first rock paper scissors we have
one environment and I'm not even gonna
try to count them in the second one but
we have like
15 environments in the in the second one
um first rock paper scissors was about
six to seven minutes long the new one is
probably about 15 16 minutes long we
have our very own custom written intro
theme song for rock paper scissors too
which is honestly probably the Pinnacle
of all the work that we did yeah
I'm excited about that as well yeah I
don't really quite know how to pronounce
his last name but David Maxim Maxine
mcchick I can't quite pronounce it but
he's this amazing metal guitarist and
song composer
um and he wrote the song for us uh you
guys check him out on Spotify and yeah
we'll put a link in the description
but more like the thing I'm honestly at
the end of the day proud of most with
rock paper scissors 2 is just that there
is a an actual full story with a full
character Arc and like
the the rock paper scissors games and
the AI filters and all that stuff was
just a way for us to open a door to your
heart and introduce you to King Phil and
Prince Jules in the land of ragovia
and get you invested in the story yeah
so
that's it
I'm excited yeah man it's gonna be great
I hope people really like it
um and I'm I'm personally excited to
just get this the next part of the story
out there and it was really cool to see
the world expand
so yeah
um it'll be coming out on Saturday yes
and I gotta say one more thing on
quarter quarterdigital.com so
this only exists because of the
subscribers on Corridor digital.com so
all of you who are listening to this
right now who are part of the website
thank you so much because there's no way
we could take four months
plus right to do an experimental like
hyper Cutting Edge technologically
experimental anime narrative yeah with
no way to be able to do that on YouTube
AdSense and there's like there's no way
to be able to do it with a brand
integration this like this only exists
because people are like hey we think
it's cool what you guys are making and
it's entertaining and fun and we want to
see more of it so
thank you so much yeah you guys are
gonna get to see rock paper scissors
very shortly here I have tutorials all
this cool stuff and if you've been
thinking about subscribing well if you
like episode two
and you want to see in episode three
or you want to see those tutorials
right now's a great time that was funny
when uh when the first one came out and
we put the tutorials behind the paywall
and some people on YouTube were very
upset about that because it was like oh
my God how can you and uh the thing was
though is like literally if we hadn't
have done that and bring some people
over to check that out
about half of the financing that we
needed to make the second one wouldn't
have happened it just wouldn't have
happened and there's no it's fun to be
you know like pie in the sky about it
and be like oh well you know can't you
just give it away and it's like no you
literally like we can't we had we have
to generate the money somewhere to pay
to to make it to make it and uh yeah
it's that's been directly because uh
website members and uh
yeah but the cool thing is it's we don't
need a Netflix user base you know we
just need you we just need you guys
watching this right now it's we can
actually support this kind of
media this kind of art I don't need 225
million Global subscribers which is
amazing stock valuation it's okay we
just need people who are passionate
about what we make to support us and
that's all we need that's all you can
really ask for that's like the future of
this stuff man it's beautiful you can
build a little Community with people who
like the same stuff that you like and
now you can make these giant sweeping
narratives with this stuff and that's
that's what's super exciting to me is
like it's actually going to be possible
for the little guy to make our big
because you know we all like we all got
into this because we wanted to make you
know
monsters shooting robots and whatever
you know like yeah like crazy imaginary
stuff and like this is it feels like
it's finally possible with like putting
this out like a full episode of
something yep yeah 100 it's cool that
it's like it's not a compliment not
compromise but it's not we have to do a
two minute YouTube short you know we got
to make a real story and yeah I know
it's not a feature like movie that's
okay
but it's still a real story and like
that's just it feels really good yeah
that that's that's the thing that I like
best about it is is we're not thinking
about oh well you know it has to be this
long or it's too short or we gotta make
a compromise it's just we're just
telling the story of the universe and
we're not worried about how long each
episode is
or how long it could or should or would
be it's just here's here's the next
episode and then here's the next episode
and then here's the next episode and you
can follow along as a viewer yep that's
it that's it just enjoy right yeah
all right good stuff I'm I'm glad we can
finally tell the world because we've
like we've just been doing this behind
closed doors yeah just we're like we're
gonna get it out there and get it done
let's not say anything until it's ready
and it's ready yeah so it's finally
coming out one week
yes sir all right well thanks for
joining everybody and uh Jonah I hope
that you took more notes during this
podcast I legitimately did that's the
crazy part is that I wrote down two
things from this podcast we'll talk
about that
um but yeah look out we'll definitely
look out for the video essay that's
coming out
um on Saturday as well
um yeah it is a lot of what we discussed
here but you'll be able to see firsthand
um what it looks like to to do this and
how you can do it yourself and as
someone who's uh you know spearheading
the tutorials I'm very passionate about
getting that knowledge out there so me
too it's not just for us it's for you
um yeah all these tools are open source
like that that's perhaps why it feels
like it moves so fast is because this
isn't happening behind like a corporate
wall yeah it's just all happening out in
the open yeah and yeah it's so cool that
you can just download it just do it you
don't have to pay anybody you don't have
to ask for permission make a tutorial
show you how that'll come in like
another 15 years when Corporate America
takes over their interests but for now
it's free boys you got a little bit of
time still yep
disabled diffusion 1.5
downloaded on my computer I'm gonna put
it on a thumb drive it down it's hands
though it's hands
well like controlling that five point
yeah whatever by the time yeah cool all
right well awesome thanks for listening
everybody
um I'm super excited for the next few
weeks here as we roll this stuff out
yep thanks for watching and uh
have a great day yeah have a wonderful
day